there's something about the cosmic
perspective which for some people is
enlightening and for other people it's
terrifying for those who are terrified
by it they're here on earth and they
have a certain self-identity and then
they learn that earth is tiny and we're
in this void of interplanetary space and
then there's a star we call the Sun and
it's kind of average and there's a
hundred billion other stars and a galaxy
and our galaxy the Milky Way is one of
fifty or a hundred billion other
galaxies in the universe and and they
with every step every window that modern
astrophysics has opened to our mind the
person who wants to feel like they are
the center of everything ends up
shrinking and for some people they might
even find it depressing I assert that if
you were depressed after learning and
being exposed to the cosmic perspective
you started your day with an
unjustifiably large ego you thought more
highly of yourself then in fact the
circumstances deserved so here's what
you do
you say I have no ego at all let's start
that way I have no ego no no no no cause
to puff myself up now let's learn about
the cosmic perspective yeah we're on a
planet that's orbiting a star and a star
is an energy source and it's giving us
energy and we're feeling this energy and
life is enabled by this energy in this
star and by the way there's a hundred
billion other stars that have other
planets there might be other life out
there could be like us it's probably not
like us or whatever it is it'd be
fascinating to find out who it is can we
talk to them can we not are they more
advanced are they less advanced by the
way the atoms of our body are traceable
to what stars do and all you can do is
sit back and bask in your relevance to
the cosmos so those who see the cosmic
perspective as a depressing
outlook they really need to reassess how
they think about the world because when
I look up in the universe I know I'm
small but I'm also big I'm big because
I'm connected to the universe and the
universe is connected to me
[Music]